police in Mexico are investigating the
murder of an American tourist hit by a
stray bullet in Mexico City 27 year old
Tatyana Mironenko of San Francisco was
there to celebrate her wedding
anniversary she was leaving a restaurant
with her husband and two friends on
Saturday morning when she was shot
Jericka Duncan is here with how the
American was caught up in the shooting
Jericka good morning good morning police
say two men on a motorcycle were aiming
for a bar bouncer who was hit and
survived now Mira tenko meanwhile her
family says they're shocked that one of
Tatiana's favorite countries to visit
became the very place where she lost her
life I want everyone to remember Tatiana
for her smile her liveliness her
optimism and adventurous spirit Tatyana
Mira tanco sister and father say she and
her husband were in Mexico City to
celebrate their first anniversary a year
ago at this time we were selecting
flowers for her wedding and yesterday we
were there selecting flowers for her
funeral
the couple was traveling with other
friends to sample mexico city's best
restaurants mira tenko was shot at a
Mexican restaurant in an upscale
neighborhood over the weekend police say
the gunmen were aiming for a bouncer
inside the restaurant but hit Mary tango
as she was leaving her family says she
had just told them how safe she felt
there we traveled to Mexico all of our
lives time has probably been there at
least 30 times according to the latest
figures from the Mexican government 2017
was the nation's deadliest year on
record with more than 25 thousand
murders earlier this year the US State
Department issued a travel ban to five
Mexican states the same warning issued
to war-torn countries like Syria
Afghanistan and Somalia popular tourist
destinations Ixtapa and al Caputo are in
those do not travel zones the government
also warns tourists to exercise
increased caution when visiting Cancun
Cozumel Playa del Carmen and Mexico City
Tatiana was an investor relations
analyst for a San Francisco
pharmaceutical firm she was also a role
model to her younger sister to me she
is who I aspire to be as a person with
everything I do and I don't know what
I'll do without her merit anko's funeral
will be held Saturday in Chicago where
she grew up police in Mexico say they
are reviewing surveillance video as they
search for the gunman and of course this
was an area that may have been a little
off the so called resort but it was a
safe area a lot of people were there she
obviously and neither did her husband
expect something like this to happen
right husband is okay husband's okay
he's physically yeah
drinka thank you